president biden meets today with members
of congress hoping to build support for
his massive
infrastructure plan the 2.3 trillion
dollar package would be one of the
biggest investments in public works
in a generation it's already been
criticized by republicans and
some democrats nancy cordes is at the
white house
nancy what do you expect from this
meeting well it's a stab at
bipartisanship anthony the president is
sitting down with four democrats
four republicans trying to find some
common ground
on infrastructure but republicans want a
package that about is about a quarter of
the size
of the one that the president has
proposed and if anything
the gulf appeared to widen this weekend
where does the spending end mississippi
senator roger wicker is among the
republicans set to sit down today with
president biden
as their party pushes back on his 2.3
trillion dollar proposal the democrat
idea always includes
increasing taxes the american jobs plan
would invest
in roads bridges water pipes airports
broadband and the electrical grid all of
it paid for by hiking the corporate tax
rate republicans argue some parts of the
plan
like an expansion of long-term care
under medicaid
don't belong in an infrastructure
package so much of it is unnecessary
six percent is actually focused on the
kind of infrastructure that
there is bipartisan support for the
figure that they use
is a ridiculous one to say that it's
just a small percentage of the bill
it is overwhelmingly what the
legislation is about
but there is no bill yet which leaves
room for bipartisanship
the president is willing to negotiate
what this looks like
he knows that that his current plan
is going to be changed one option would
be to try to break the package into
several pieces
but the white house argues all the
elements are designed to strengthen the
economy
and create jobs to me it makes no sense
to say
i would have been for broadband but i'm
against it because it's not a bridge
i would have been for elder care but i'm
against it because it's not a highway
on 60 minutes last night federal reserve
chair jerome powell said the economy is
actually
about to take off what they're
forecasting is growth for this year in
the range of six or seven percent
which would be the highest level in you
know 30 years
uh or even maybe a little bit higher it
seems like you're not expecting a
recovery you're expecting a boom
well i would say that this growth that
we're expecting in the second half of
this year
is going to be very strong but one thing
he said could derail that
the principal risk to our economy right
now really is that the
disease would spread again
cabinet secretaries say that the
president wants to see
significant movement by memorial day so
that's the window for bipartisanship
here and if he can't get
consensus by then he may try to go it
alone with democrats but that
is a fraught path too because there are
some progressives tony
who want to see a package that's four
times the size
of the one the president has proposed
boy no easy path forward nancy thank you
very much